(Risas)
Son ojitos plásticos.
Me tomaron 14 horas y 227 ojos plásticos para hacer esta blusa.
Pero ser capaz de mirarlos a Uds. tanto como Uds. a mí
es solo una parte de la razón para que hiciera esto,
la otra parte es poder hacer esto.
(Ojos cascabeleando)
(Risas)
Hago muchas cosas como esta.
Veo un problema e invento algun tipo de solución.
Por ejemplo, cepillarse los dientes.
Es algo que todos tenemos que hacer, es algo aburrido
y muchos detestan.
Si hubiera niños de 7 años en el público estarían diciendo "¡Sí!"
Pues bien, ¿qué tal una máquina que lo hiciera por nosotros?
(Risas)
Lo llamo...
lo llamo el "casco cepillador de dientes"
(Risas)
(Brazo robótico)
(Aplausos)
Bueno, 0 de cada 10 dentistas recomiendan este casco.
Y está claro que no revolucionó el mundo de la odontología,
pero sí cambió mi vida de manera radical.
Porque cuando terminé de fabricar ese casco hace tres años;
después de diseñarlo, fui a mi sala, instalé una cámara
y grabé un video de siete segundos, mientras funcionaba.
Y ahora, esto se tornó en un típico cuento de hadas moderno,
en el que una chica publica algo en internet
y se convierte en un éxito en la red.
Miles de hombres dejan sus comentarios para pedir su mano en matrimonio.
(Risas)
Ella ignora a todos, abre un canal en YouTube
y sigue fabricando robots.
Desde entonces, me he forjado este pequeño nicho en internet
como inventora de máquinas inservibles.
Porque, como todos saben,
la manera más fácil de llegar a la cima de nuestro campo
es elegir un campo muy pequeño.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Así que abrí un canal en YouTube para mis inventos,
haciendo cosas como cortar el cabello con drones.
(Dron volando)
(Risas)
(Primer dron cae)
(Segundo dron volando)
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y también una máquina que me despierta por la mañana.
(Alarma)
(Risas)
(Video) Simone: ¡Au!
Y una máquina que me ayuda a cortar verduras.
(Cuchillos cortando)
No soy ingeniera, no estudié ingeniería en la universidad;
pero fui una alumna sumamente ambiciosa.
En la escuela secundaria tenía las notas más altas
y me gradué como la mejor alumna.
Pero por otro lado,
luché contra una grave ansiedad por mi desempeño escolar.
Este es un correo que envié a mi hermano por esa fecha.
"No imaginarías lo difícil que es para mí decirte esto,
confesarte esto.
Estoy terriblemente avergonzada, no quiero que los demás me crean tonta.
Ya estoy empezando a llorar.
Maldición".
Pues no, no es que haya incendiado la casa de mis padres por error.
El motivo de este correo, y de lo que tanto me angustiaba,
era que había sacado una B en una prueba de matemática.
Evidentemente, algo pasó entre eso y esto.
(Risas)
Una de esas cosas fue la pubertad.
Hermosa época, claro.
Pero por otro lado,
empecé a interesarme en la fabricación de robots,
y decidí aprender de hardware por mí misma.
Pero construir cosas con hardware, especialmente como autodidacta,
es algo muy difícil de hacer.
Las posibilidades de fracasar son altas
y, además, también son altas las probabilidades de sentirse torpe.
Y ese fue mi mayor temor en ese entonces.
Se me ocurrió entonces una idea que garantizara el éxito en un 100 %.
Con esa idea, sería casi imposible fracasar.
Ella consistía en renunciar a la idea del éxito
y, en su lugar, tratar de hacer cosas que fracasaran.
Y si bien en ese momento no me daba cuenta,
construir cosas tontas sí fue una decisión inteligente;
porque mientras aprendía de hardware por primera vez en mi vida,
no tenía que enfrentar la ansiedad por mi desempeño.
En cuanto me liberé de la presión y de las expectativas para conmigo misma,
esa presión fue rápidamente reemplazada por el entusiasmo,
y eso me permitió divertirme.
De modo que, como inventora, me interesan las cosas que nos suponen un problema.
Pueden ser cosas de tamaño pequeño, mediano o grande,
como esta charla en TED, que me presenta una serie de nuevos retos por resolver.
Así que identificar un problema es el primer paso
del proceso para construir una máquina inservible.
Asi que antes de venir aquí,
me puse a pensar en los posibles problemas que podría tener
al dar esta charla.
Olvidar lo que debía decir,
que la gente no se ría,
o sea ustedes.
O peor aún, que se rían de lo que no debieran.
Esta es una parte que deben reír.
Gracias.
(Risas)
O que me temblaran las manos por los nervios
y que eso me diera vergüenza.
O que tuviera la bragueta abierta durante toda la charla
y todos se den cuenta excepto yo;
pero sí la tengo cerrada, así que sí estamos bien en ello.
Aunque lo que sí me preocupa es cuando me tiemblan las manos.
Recuerdo cuando de pequeña daba la lección en la escuela,
tenía mis anotaciones en un papel, y lo ponía encima de un cuaderno
para que los demás no vieran cómo lo hacía temblar.
Y ahora doy muchas charlas.
Sé que quizá la mitad de los presentes pensarán,
"Hacer máquinas inservibles es divertido,
pero ¿cómo puede ser un trabajo?"
Dar charlas sí es parte de ello.
Y los organizadores siempre ponen un vaso de agua para el orador;
el cual puede tomarlo cuando tiene sed.
Y como siempre tengo ganas de tomar esa agua,
pero no me atrevo a levantar el vaso
por temor a que el público vea que me tiemblan las manos.
Entonces, ¿qué tal una máquina que me alcance el vaso de agua?
Vendido a la chica con la polera de ojos plásticos...
Bueno, tengo que sacarme esto porque me incomoda.
(Ojos plásticos cascabeleando)
Oh.
(Ruido metálico)
(Risas)
Todavía no sé qué nombre ponerle,
pero puede ser "dispositivo orbital craneal",
porque esta plataforma gira alrededor de uno
y se puede poner de todo en ella.
Se puede poner una cámara para que saque fotos de toda la cabeza.
Podría decirse que es una máquina versátil.
(Risas)
Bien, también...
por ejemplo, se pueden poner algunos bocadillos si lo desean.
Estas son palomitas de maíz.
Se puede poner un poco aquí...
y luego...
bueno, un sacrificio para la ciencia, son solo palomitas que pueden caer.
Lo hacemos girar todo.
(Robot funcionando)
(Risas)
Y luego tenemos una mano pequeña
que hay que poner a la altura correcta, solo con los hombros.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Tiene una mano pequeña.
(La mano da un golpe)
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Acabo de golpear el micrófono, pero está todo bien.
Bien, tengo que comer estas palomitas;
así que si pudieran aplaudir un poco más...
(Aplausos)
Esto es como un sistema solar personal;
y ya que soy una milenial,
quiero que todo gire a mi alrededor.
(Risas)
Volviendo al vaso de agua, para lo cual estamos aquí,
prometo que... bueno.
No, no tiene agua,
perdón.
Pero aún debo trabajar un poco más con esta máquina,
porque me falta levantar el vaso y ponerlo en la plataforma,
pero si sus manos tiemblan solo un poco, nadie lo notará
porque se obtendrá un efecto distractor con el equipo.
Entonces, todo bien.
Bien.
(Robot funcionando)
Oh no, se atascó.
¿No es un alivio que hasta un robot a veces tenga pánico escénico?
Como que se traba un poco.
Tiene una lado muy humano.
Esperen, retrocedamos un poco,
y luego...
(El vaso se cae)
(Risas)
¿No es un momento maravilloso para estar vivos?
(Aplausos)
Si bien mis máquinas pueden parecer simples payasadas de ingeniería,
me di cuenta que he encontrado algo mucho más grande que eso.
Como la expresión de alegría y humildad que se suele perder en la ingeniería
y que para mí fue la manera de aprender todo esto
sin que intervenga mi ansiedad por tener un buen desempeño.
A menudo me preguntan si alguna vez podré hacer algo útil,
y quizá algún día lo haga.
Pero en mi opinión, ya lo logré,
porque me inventé este trabajo
y eso es algo que nunca podría haber planeado o que...
(Aplaussos)
Esto es algo que nunca planeé, pero sucedió
porque puse pasión en lo que hacía,
y compartí ese entusiasmo con otra gente.
Para mí, allí está la verdadera belleza de hacer cosas inútiles,
porque significa reconocer que no siempre sabemos
cuál es la respuesta correcta.
Eso calla esa voz en nuestra cabeza
que nos hace creer que sabemos cómo funciona exactamente el mundo.
Y quizá un casco cepillador no sea la respuesta,
pero al menos uno se hace una pregunta.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)